so your why comes from your past
um everybody has a y every individual
has a y it's our god-given right
um uh uh it is who we are and it comes
it is basically an origin story that's
what a y
is so it's the sum total of how we were
raised the things we learned from our
parents that made us who we are today
and there's no changing who we are all
that matter all that we can do is either
be in balance or out of balance
so when you do things inconsistent with
who you are people say things like it's
like i don't know who you are anymore
right um think of a y like the
foundation of a house
it's it's solid and everything else gets
built on top of that
so if you suffer some sort of tragedy or
trauma
and things get knocked down you rebuild
on the same foundation
ancient ruins we lose the buildings we
always have the foundation
it's the thing we build upon it's who we
are and the same goes for our businesses
our businesses have a why it's why we
started them
most of us who start businesses we're
there's a reason to take that
overwhelming risk of failure there's a
reason that
feels worth it right that it's worth the
sacrifice and the hard work
and it's not just because i want to be
my own boss because sometimes being in
your own boss is
not worth all the extra effort and
sometimes you don't even make as much
money
there's something that drives somebody
to want to own their own business
that origin story that reason that
compelled you
is the why so the why comes from the
past it's a foundation we build upon it
it's
objective a just cause is about the
future
it's about where we're going it's
subjective we can we can build any
future we want we can decide the future
we want to build and
head towards it can you change your just
cause i guess you can
i wouldn't change it too often because
then you're a moving target
um you can't change your y the
foundation the house but you can change
the paint on the house you can change
the shutters
you can change if you want to be a big
or small house you can change it at any
time but you still want it going in the
same direction built upon that
[Music]
foundation